the struggle to recover from Hurricane
Harvey satellite photos show what some
of the hardest hit areas looked like
before Harvey touched down and what they
look like now after the historic storm
passed through overnight emergency crews
continued to deal with the fallout from
a massive fire and explosions at a
flooded Houston area chemical plant
evacuations they are expected to
continue as the company expects the
remaining containers to explode at any
time
Harvey is being blamed for at least 40
deaths almost 125,000 customers are
still without power
today President Trump will make his
second visit to the disaster zone as the
federal government begins the process to
help the Gulf Coast recover we have a
team of correspondents throughout East
Texas we start with Kris Van Cleave
who's been monitoring the situation at
that chemical plant in Crosby Texas
Chris good morning
good morning the fire crews behind us
here are essentially waiting for the
next fire to start the chemical plant
says that could happen at any minute but
even when it does there's not a whole
lot the firefighters can do about it
they're going to have to let the fire
burn itself out because it's just too
dangerous to go in and fight it directly
huge flames shoot from some of the eight
trailers containing explosively unstable
organic peroxide inside the Arkham a
chemical plant as the smoke billowed
sheriff's deputies more than a mile away
put on protective gear including gas
masks earlier some residents living near
the plant tried to get around a
mandatory evacuation order to go back
home
Santa trammel was met with roadblocks
because of the explosion Rios why didn't
we just want to get back here and see on
Thursday a 9th container exploded and
burst into flames after the flood
knocked out the plants refrigeration
system that keeps the volatile chemicals
stable the smoke from that fire sent 18
police and paramedics to the hospital
with symptoms ranging from lost voices
to dizziness to choking
more explosions are imminent but Friday
we were able to get a look at the plant
just a couple of hours before the fire
started
vehicles remain submerged and parts of
the facility are still waterlogged are
you worried about these these explosions
they're talking about and why yeah you
never know they haven't been bad but
they could get bad when a Dargo was
trying to make it home to get more
medication we had no water problems at
all our problem was just because of this
chemical plant and we don't know when we
can get in who's going to notify us when
we can come back nobody's told us
anything the plant houses a number of
potentially dangerous chemicals but the
company in assists that those are
isolated away from where these trailers
are and that the fire shouldn't impact
those other dangerous chemicals but the
smoke itself can be an irritant and can
cause breathing problems that's part of
why there's a mile-and-a-half evacuation
zone Anthony all right Kris Van Cleave
and Crosby Texas thank you Chris